you're asking if i'm passionate about
what we are doing if i'm happy with that
it's amazing
we are in a revolution so when we've
started the company
everyone looked at us now okay what are
those guys talking about now
the largest um
ev charging network in the us evgo is
our customer since
2017. we are the largest in japan
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
speaking with don frankel the ceo of
drives talking about electric vehicles
and talking about how cloud integrates
into this whole ecosystem of a mobility
drone is an experienced entrepreneur
with over 25 years of international
management experience in the ev charging
telecommunications and fleet industries
prior to drives dawn was co-founder and
ceo of we secure and before that he held
the position of general manager of the
israeli operations at sphera
as a director at mdocs duon led business
relationships worth hundreds of millions
of dollars with top customers such as
nextel and t-mobile
i'm excited to
to tell a little bit about the story
uh of a 10-year journey from a company
that is in a space that
you know is big question marks on its
existence to a place where it's booming
everybody knows it and and it is a
leading company in the in the market so
it's i'm really excited to hear about
you yourself drives the the technology
you're building and and some of these
ideas that you've uncovered so thank you
for being here
thank you so much so yes the journey
started about 10 years ago um
and back then ev electrical vehicles
were a big question mark will it happen
what is that
and when i looked at the market what i
understood is that if it happens it's a
revolution it can be small it's huge
it's an old sound game
yeah it's a smaller nutting game and as
someone that came from the telco
business and i've seen this revolution
happens
i i what i had in mind is you know what
if it's a revolution it's interesting
because you can make a change right you
can contribute to change and you know
what you can make money out of it
what i soon realized is that we're in
the middle of two revolutions the
mobility revolution and the energy
revolution so two revolutions at the
same time then jump and do that and i
just want to make sure to differentiate
two of two revolutions
energy and and mobility people often
conflate the two and put them together
assuming that energy is a part of the
mobility revolution you're saying that
they're two separate revolutions
two separate revolutions because
mobility once you get into ev and
autonomous vehicles it's a whole
revolution but from energy perspective
we are looking at the greener world
we're looking at renewables we're
looking at way beyond the car
way beyond the cars
we'll see that the other thing is if you
look at how much the if you look at
pollution so about 30 to 40 percent of
the pollution is coming from
transportation
but if we'll turn it into evs then we'll
have more from the energy more pollution
from energy so if energy is about 30 to
40 percent it will grow
so now we have a challenge and what i
can show you is how we link those things
together actually how do you use the ev
revolution the electrical vehicle
revolution to support us in the energy
revolution
so
that's part of of the of the passion
when we started it was a big question
mark about evs and then to connect evs
and energies together it was more
challenging and it was even crazy today
it's revealed you see that most of the
vehicle manufacturers if not all are
moving to evs
they are declared that they are not
investing in combustion engine vehicles
anymore it's all about evs
so now how do you cope with all of that
so what we've started
the question mark was first of all will
ev happen what are we going to do in
this space and for me digital services
platforms the software behind managing
that
that was my domain expertise that's what
i wanted to focus on
so if you want to develop the best
operating system for ev charging and
energy management once the market ramps
up the question is when will it ramp up
and how do you finance it until it ramps
up
now if we fast forward for today today
we are operating in um over 25 countries
we have over one million drivers on the
platform wow we um operate both from the
energy side and the vehicle side we're
doing both
billing
energy management and on top of all of
that
we found out that the charger
environment the charges are not as
stable as you want them to be
so the drivers gets to the charger and
it doesn't work there are so many issues
around it because you have different
software in the charger different
software in the car it's a really
complex environment
and our first large customer was in 2014
it was a company called elad it lad is
charged in dutch yeah it was uh it is a
company in the netherlands
and once we migrated them from their
previous networks to our platform we
found out that there are lots of issues
with the charges and there is no one
type of charger
what we did is we developed first of all
monitoring tools to understand where are
the issues if there are issues
and then we converted that into
self-healing we started to get into more
sophisticated tools so we know how to
fix things in the chargers remotely
before even the operator or the driver
knows about it
so self-healing and operational
excellence is the number one thing
before you get into
billing and energy management
then the second thing is
we need to realize that eventually you
have drivers and drivers wants to enjoy
life or to do what they need to do for
their businesses same as fleets
but it's a really really complex
environment so how do you manage that so
we develop a platform that serves the
operators the guys that are
managing the network of charges
and we provide them the operational
tools um
energy management billing roaming
roaming is the ability for someone to
charge in one network that register in
one network to charge on the other so
it's about roaming and why and why is
that
why why is that a an interesting feature
important because think about you as a
driver so you signed up to one network
and anyhow you don't have enough public
charges yeah so the network
is small
right even if it will be big as you are
used to now to use different
cellular providers
and you used to call someone from
another network the same is for charging
so you can be registered to many
different kind of operators or you can
have one
then and then if it's roaming then you
can use the other networks as well sure
so this is sort of the consolidation
that we see now also within our our own
network which is you know regardless of
where i'm registered there are services
now that sort of consolidate all the
different cell towers so i can use
whichever one i'm closest to and they
sort of pay them by usage right i mean i
guess it's a similar idea it's very
similar a bit of even more complex
because it's now also about energy
management
so what we provide we provide the tools
to the operators but we also provide the
tools as white labeled apps and hotels
to the drivers
and the drivers needs to charge whenever
they are so you don't drive
to fuel or drive to charge you charge
where you are
sure about 20 about 80 of the charging
is at home and work
only 20 percent is public and three
percent is in gas stations
so think about that we we are now here
in a high tech campus there is a gas
station at the entrance
and eventually only three percent will
happen in the gas station the rest is
going to be in the facility so cni
commercial industrial buildings are
going to be
kind of the fueling parts
of interest of the future
now the other thing is if most of the
charging is being done at home and walk
do you have enough power
to charge how do you manage that so for
instance in the building that we are in
there is no power anymore for evs so it
started we have three and we have three
parking underground and one outside it
started that
minus one parking didn't have enough
power
so then what we do is we have solutions
that are doing load balancing so we
don't charge the vehicles simultaneously
we charge
one and one and one and one and then we
get up to the limit and only then once
you fill it up you get to the next
vehicle and so on so
from a consumer experience if you do
that then
then won't consumers you know put the
car to charge expect a certain charge by
the end of the day i mean how will they
sort of know to expect how much charge
they're going to get from a single
session they need to expect to get what
they need we need to balance it
if we try to do all of that at once the
breakers will break or you won't have
enough energy anyhow no no of course
yeah so what we do we balance it now
the charging itself i'm driving a
vehicle that drives 420 kilometers per
charge but normally on a day-to-day
basis and
driving only 10 kilometers so i don't
need it all the time
we will talk about something else which
is called vehicle to grid later on i can
also provide energy back to the grid
that's so cool what we what happened is
that okay so we balance it we decide
which one is charging if it's a
salesperson probably will give you more
priority or if it's a vhp we'll give you
more priority
but also then it's not enough so what do
you do
we are adding renewables and in our case
we also are adding batteries
that we charge overnight and we use the
batteries to charge the vehicles
throughout the day
okay so you can bring batteries from a
centralized source of power
outside bring it in and those batteries
can now be used to charge and so you're
adding an additional grid to the to the
power supply of the building yeah we
actually uh also acquired the company
and israeli company that developed a
very unique technology
where if you're looking at batteries the
weakest cell wins
so if you are looking at the remote
control you are told all the time
replace both batteries simultaneously
because the weakest battery will take
the energy
so what they did is they have those
you just opened up i just have to say
open a whole new world for me with
remotes and uh
now things are making a lot more sense i
didn't know that rule that you replaced
both at the same time
i should know this this is a little
embarrassing for me so what happens is
they have those chips that sits on top
of the batteries and they decide which
which models to keep or not
so eventually you get almost twice as
much as the capacity you have but that's
not only the the case you can use first
life batteries but also second life
batteries
if you are using second life batteries
you solve a big problem of what happens
with the batteries of the cars
when they are over where they are not
useful for anymore for the vehicles you
can use them as storage to assist ev
charging or more so this is an example
of a company that we have integrated the
solution between our software platform
and their software solution on top of
the batteries and then we can serve more
we can provide more power to to the
different users
so it's about energy management
on top of everything else that you have
so within drives what we have is uh the
ability to provide white label
applications for the drivers but we also
have another thing which is a whole set
of solutions for fleets
for buildings
for mdu for apartment buildings and why
do you need that if you're a fleet
manager you need to make sure that the
vehicles are charged on time you don't
care about right charging and complexity
so how do you make sure that
it's charged on time you need to have
scheduling
what we did is we delegated the
responsibility
either to the fleet manager or even to
the secretaries of the cni of the
tenants of the cni building the
commercial the
like
workplaces so the secretaries can define
who is charging when
and beyond that what happens with me uh
i'm every morning i need to plug my car
in and start the charge and in many
cases i have a phone call and i forget
forget just two notes swipe the card
now so what happens
i don't have enough power in the evening
right because i forgot right now we have
alerts so the secretaries knows that i
haven't start the chart when i was
supposed to and they can do it for me
remotely
see so we are delegating the
responsibility and it makes my life a
lot easier so we have a whole set of
solutions also for this entire ecosystem
so it's for the operators for the
buildings for the fleets and also for
the end users
in the buildings themselves yes sorry
i i mean i'm i'm curious from a from an
entrepreneurship perspective from a
maybe more strategic perspective it
sounds like you're tackling three
verticals that
you know three of them are sort of an an
integral part of this
revolution you know for the for the ev
space
and and i'm wondering you know what was
the decision to to tackle all three
verses and they were maybe narrowed down
on just one of them and really double
down on it because
they do sound overlapping but not
completely so i tell you where we are
focus we are focused on large operators
because
what we believe on is that eventually
you will have consolidation in the
market like we had in the telco space
and once you do have those this
consolidation you'll see big companies
that are swallowing the smaller
companies and they need the solution
that will fit their needs so i'll give
you an example
one of our customers is a company called
startcraft
their ev charging brand is mere
starcraft is the largest renewable
company in in europe
okay so and they bought different
companies they bought the button file
activity in the uk two companies in in
germany one fleet oriented and one is
targeted on cpo charge point operator
the second biggest in sweden the second
business biggest in norway
all of those kind of different companies
that they acquired we migrated them away
into the drives platform
so we now manage some of the charges are
public some of them are fleet some of
them are home charges so you need to
support those this environment with the
different verticals but it's similar
solutions to them
the other net interesting thing is also
about energy management because it's the
largest renewable company so how do we
integrate ev charging with energy
management
and
it gets in back into the vision
so our vision
is
looking at uh at the energy world and we
believe that we can drop the co2
emission
dramatically and we can create a lot
better world for our generations to come
by looking at the evs as battery on
wheels and let me try and sketch
something for you so the way that the
energy consumption is uh is done on a
day
looks like that a small peak that's 24
hours a small peak in the morning and
then a bigger peak in the evening
and if you look at that the
energy generation
we generate
to the peak because you can't stop the
transformers and we'll talk about
renewables in a second
it means that all this energy
is gone by pollution
and by money which is wasted
so what would we like to do we would
like to
generate half of the energy like that
store it in the off peak and use it in
the peak store it on the off peak and
use it on the peak like that
if we do that we can generate half
right so how do you store energy
i'm following this you store energy in
the batteries yeah where do you have big
batteries
in the vehicles where in the evs
so if we'll start
those are
aren't you then limited
by nature you know each car can in at
maximum
be provide half of itself because you're
using second life batteries right while
talking about the vehicles themselves so
it's first life batteries of the
vehicles themselves
so if you look at the vehicles
themselves that is the vehicle-to-grid
right if you look at the vehicles
themselves
then think about it you have huge amount
of vehicles who are going to have huge
amount of vehicles whilst the market
ramps up
and if you look at that and you're
looking at the evs as battery on wheels
you can charge and discharge
it means that you can actually pay the
driver
for the energy as a utility as opposed
to him paying
for energy
so it's about energy balancing
it's not only
vehicle to x v to x or v to grid it's
about also when you charge you can
decide if you charge in the morning in
the evening how do you manage all of
that
and if you look at that statistically
with ai artificial intelligence then you
can decide when to charge when to take
back energy
it means that not only you're using the
evs as a tool to reduce the pollution
because it's cleaner
you can also use the evs as a tool
for a lot better
reason which is balancing the grid
and if you use that as an additional
tool to balance the grid
uh you can create a better world for our
kids right you can drop the co2
emissions dramatically
and make money out of it so you know
so if you're asking if i'm passionate
about what we are doing if i'm happy
with that it's amazing
we are in a revolution so when we've
started the company
everyone looked at us now okay what are
those guys talking about now
the largest um
ev charging network in the us evgo is
our customer since 2017
the largest in ireland
since 2015 we are the largest in japan
only in japan there are 27 000 stations
9 000 fast
so if you're looking at that it's huge
amount of stations but it's more than
that
we expect that within several years uh
around 25 26 probably
once the cost of our combustion engine
car and the cost of the ev will be equal
we won't see only a ramp up which is
huge of what we see now we'll see a
hockey stick
so we need to be ready with the
solutions with the energy management
with the billing with all of that until
then
okay
so you need to beat the inflection point
that's your goal and to create a better
world for kids
and to make money right now so all of
that comes together
100 all of the consequences and the
positive impact is amazing but but i
love the
the tenacity of saying you know what
there is this going to be inflection
point
after that inflection point
whatever we have that's what we have for
the infrastructure because it's going to
be a hockey stick so either we find
ourselves in big trouble you know
chasing after our own tail or we make it
to the inflection point obviously
hopefully with drives being a leading
figure there and and make it a a an
incredible um opportunity and impact and
dawn i really want to thank you for for
being here
20 minutes is not nearly enough but
certainly it really sparked my curiosity
and and i and i'm really happy that you
were here and sharing this story with me
and uh thank you very much thank you so
much mikhail it's a pleasure thanks a
lot
[Music]